bonjour christian cambon merci de
répondre à nos questions directes sur
arte france vous avez remis récemment à
gérard larcher le président du sénat un
rapport conjoint a fait au nom du sénat
français et du conseil de la fédération
de russie sur l'agenda de confiance
entre paris et moscou à jardin de
confiance ça veut dire quoi
un agenda confiance est l'expression qui
a caractérisé la rencontre entre le
président de la république
emmanuel macron et le président poutine
l'été dernier à jada de confiance il ya
deux mots agenda ça veut dire qu'il ya
un calendrier et la confiance parce que
il ya la volonté de la france de
maintenir le dialogue et de l'enrichir
et de le développer entre nos deux pays
parce que nous considérons que la russie
est une grande puissance que dans les
crises qui secoue actuellement le monde
et dieu sait s'il y en a aucune ne peut
se régler sans la russie sans la
présence et l'intervention de la russie
donc il nous semblait important de
compléter sur le plan parlementaire le
travail qu'a fait le président de la
république que l'on voit à l'image dans
cette séquence de l'été dernier à l'été
dernier c'était le 19 août exactement
quand vladimir poutine est venu au fort
de brégançon fait pratiquement un an
depuis qu'est ce qui a changé au niveau
des relations entre paris et moscou en
un an
il ya des des points de désaccord qui
demeure nous et nous n'avons jamais
entreprise ce dialogue avec l'idée de
camoufler les points de divergence et d'
analyse
différentes je pense effectivement à ce
qui se passe en syrie je pense
évidemment à à l'ukraine malgré là
encore les tentatives qui sont
régulièrement menées afin de trouver des
éléments de solution car on voit bien
que cette affaire de l'ukraine gêne
beaucoup le développement de nos
relations mais tout
tout à côté il ya beaucoup de points de
coopération qui sont très importants je
pense notamment à ce qui relève de la
lutte contre le terrorisme
la russie et la france ont eu chacune à
souffrir au combien de du jihadisme du
terrorisme est donc là je pense qu'il ya
des sujets de coopération
il ya aussi une piste très importante
qui autour de du renouveau du
multilatéralisme et d'une nouvelle
sécurité en europe à base de réflexion
sur le désarmement doit nous permettre
de travailler ensemble et puis bien sûr
il ya des coopérations qui marche très
bien
je pense aux coopérations scientifiques
culturels universitaires et nous
souhaitons bien évidemment que les
échanges économiques s'intensifient et
donc c'est un petit peu la revue de
toutes ces coopérations que nous passons
à travers ce rapport qui est une forme
très originale d'expression du parlement
puisque c'est un rapport qui a été écrit
avec les deux parties c'est à dire que
il y assure chacun des chapitres les
observations des sénateurs français les
observations de nos collègues du conseil
de la fédération russe
vous avez évoqué les points de désaccord
entre la russie et la france et
notamment le dossier ukrainien on sait
qu'il ya eu des rendez vous au sommet
normandie on le rappelle centre paris
moscou kiev et berlin justement il ya eu
des récentes réunions format normandie
le 9 décembre
anthony cros l'a souligné une venue de
vladimir poutine à paris a eu également
le 30 avril et par visioconférence
puisqu'il y avait là la crise la crise
sanitaire est ce que on peut s'attendre
à une avancée sur ce terrain cet après
midi entre les deux hommes écoutez nous
l'espérons nous l'espérons parce que
cette affaire de l'ukraine elle était un
petit peu au coeur des difficultés que
le dialogue entre la france et la russie
et d'une manière générale entre la
russie et l'europe ont pu connaître
parce que comme vous le savez cette
affaire de l'ukraine et de la crimée ont
entraîné un certain de sanctions est par
définition les sanctions paralyse les
échanges
la france a beaucoup souffert du reste
de ses sanctions sans doute aussi la
russie mais nous pensons qu'il faut
aller de l'avant et trouver les voies et
moyens de faire bouger les lignes vers
bouger les choses nous ne trouvons pas
pour l'instant que les choses évoluent
vraiment il ya eu certes des échanges de
prisonniers et la position française est
la plus objective possible c'est à dire
que lorsque nous avons nous rencontrons
des dirigeants iraniens nous avons reçu
au sénat le président aulas qui on lui a
demandé le président larcher lui a
demandé de respecter la par
l'ukrainienne des accords de minsk et
notamment la loi relative à la
régionalisation la décentralisation qui
tarde et qui ne facilite pas le dialogue
et puis bien sûr la cessation des
violences nous paraît un élément
important parce que au coeur de l'europe
est assez de points chauds comme ça dans
le monde pour ne pas en avoir de nouveau
et donc moi j'espère véritablement que
le dialogue entreprise de la république
et le président poutine vous permettre d
avancer
emmanuel macron je serai également
abordé le dossier libyen il se dit je
cite un cas du comportement russe en
libye pourquoi pas parce que la libye
est en train de s'enfoncer
dans une crise sans pareil il ya d'abord
eu les flux d'immigration mais
maintenant on voit bien que la libye est
le théâtre d'une d'opération et d'une
sorte de confrontation qui est en train
d'intervenir entre les turcs et la libye
qui pourraient même déboucher sur une
partition de ce pays
ce que personne ne souhaite et il ya
quand même des éléments inquiétants
la russie fait stationner une escadrille
de chasseurs bombardiers la nature qui
vous l'avez vu mobilise des troupes a
récemment agressé vous le savez un
bateau français au large de la libye
alors que nous étions dans une opération
de surveillance des opérations d'embargo
des arts donc tout ça est évidemment
très inquiétant c'est aux portes de
l'europe en est nous ne sommes pas si
loin et donc je pense que le président
de la république a raison d'attirer
l'attention du président poutine sur les
conséquences que cela peut avoir
nous avons su en visite officielle et je
participais à cette visite lundi le
président de la tunisie et qui en
quelque sorte nous a adressé un appel au
sco pour dire essayer de nous aider car
la proximité de toute cette violence de
toute cette agitation est évidemment
excessivement dangereuse pour la
stabilité des pays avoisinants
outre le fait que on le sait la libye
alimente une bonne part de tous les
trafics qui se dirige vers le sahel où
là les français ont une part importante
pour maintenir la sécurité de cette
région
justement à le voir à vos côtés cette
visioconférence entre emmanuel macron et
vladimir poutine a commencé il ya
quelques instants on voit des images en
direct entre le chef de l'elysée
et le chef du kremlin pour revenir
également sur les relations entre la
russie et la france s'en souvient et
christian cambon du discours des manuels
macron face aux diplomates au quai
d'orsay à l'automne dernier emmanuel
macron qui a prôné un rapprochement vers
vers la russie où en est-on exactement
l'europe qui va de lisbonne à
vladivostok
on se souvient de cette phrase inde
emmanuel macron gt gt présents à
l'elysée lors de ce discours et pour ma
part j'ai approuvé car j'ai toujours
souhaité j'ai toujours à prouver c'était
un point de désaccord avec le précédent
président de la république est toujours
souhaité pour ma part et nos amis russes
ne savent très bien que ce dialogue et
puissent se nourrir
pas uniquement de parole
un dialogue ça veut dire se dire la
vérité entre amis souligné les points
sur lequel on n'est pas d'accord parce
que il est toujours mieux de parler
plutôt que dirt 2 de rester dans
l'ignorance ou dans le silence et donc
c'est ce que nous essayons de faire et
j'essaie de le faire notamment avec mon
ami et homologue le président constantin
kosatchev nous essayons pour notre part
de montrer que sur tous les dossiers que
nous abordons et bien il y a à la fois
des secteurs qui marchent bien j'ai
évoqué tout à l'heure il ya des points
de progression qui sont indiscutables il
ya des sujets qui fâchent je le dis
sincèrement on a on a dû subir quelques
cyber attaques ont tout le monde connaît
cette histoire
de la même manière nous avons eu
l'occasion de souligner par exemple que
vous avez d'ailleurs des épreuves de ce
que vous avez fait ce qu'ils doivent en
avoir en ont et nous les donne j'ai
présidé la délégation aux renseignements
pendant toute l'année dernière et on a
eu un certain nombre d'éléments
maintenant ce n'est pas à moi
d'attribuer à qui que ce soit il ya eu
des présomptions vous souvenez du disco
de toulouse aussi où la ministre des
armées avait évoqué le fait que d'un
satellite russe s'était approché d'un
satellite français bon voilà ça fait
partie des ça fait partie des méthodes
de nos services mais je pense qu'il faut
tenter d'éviter justement cela parce que
entre amis bas il ya des choses qu'il
faut il ne faut pas trop faire et puis
s'il ya des comportements du côté
français qui nécessitent d'être corrigés
il faut nous le dire et c c'est la
franchise et la clarté de ce dialogue
que moi je souhaite avoir
on n'est pas là pour gommer les
difficultés on n'est pas de pays qui
sont alignés l'un sur l'autre nous
sommes de grandes puissances si les gens
tous les deux au conseil de sécurité
nous avons donc des responsabilités et
donc la moindre des choses passées de
faire ce que je vois à l'écran c'est à
dire de se parler comme le président de
macron parle actuellement président
poutine
je pense que ça va dans le bon sens on
affronte les difficultés et finalement
avec un peu de bonne volonté si on a
envie véritablement 2
d'apporter des solutions il y aura des
voies de dialogue qui ce qui ce se
trouveront il ya eu déjà sur le crâne
j'y reviens à l'instant nature et des
échanges de prisonniers c'est toujours
un bon signe quand on commence
effectivement à faire baisser la tension
il faut aussi faire taire les armes il
ya toujours des gens qui en veulent plus
des deux côtés qui sont plus belliqueux
c'est le rôle des grands responsables de
le faire et par exemple en afrique où
vous le savez du fait de notre présence
et nos interventions
il ya un peu de sentiments anti français
nous nous demandons que l'on prenant en
compte le travail que fait la france et
on n'est pas dans un comportement
colonies liste on est là pour assurer la
paix et la sécurité dans cette région
d'afrique qui est très menacé merci à
christian cambon rester avec nous je
vous propose d'écouter ce direct
manuel macouin delà des murs poutine qui
s'entretiennent donc par visioconférence
[Musique]
quelques aspects sanaa plus efficace
harmattan nom plein là et on
l'argent c'est le terrorisme
[Musique]
le mans climatique l'économie dans le
large sens du mot
selon liés
[Musique]
voilà connexion difficile christian
cambon vous êtes vous êtes toujours avec
nous on avait du mal à entendre les
divers mots échangés entre vladimir
poutine et emmanuel macron selon vous où
ils sont en train de parler 3 en ce
moment à écouter ce que j'ai entendu
aller dans le sens de ce que j'évoquais
et je crois qu'il jouit enfin ils ont
évoqué où il évoque actuellement de deux
sujets sains pour deux ou trois sujets
importants la lutte commune contre le
terrorisme
encore une fois la russie et la france
ont payé un prix très élevé 1 au
terrorisme djihadiste je les ai entendus
dans les bribes de conversations que
nous avons saisi la dimension
environnementale je pense que la russie
là aussi a beaucoup à apporter beaucoup
à nous aider elle même souffre du
réchauffement climatique on l'a vu avec
des reportages récents sur la sibérie et
puis et bien sûr la dimension sanitaire
de la crise que nous venons de connaître
l'ensemble des pandémies qui maintenant
sont aussi redoutables que que les
armements conventionnels et je pense que
sur ces sujets là on a beaucoup de
choses à dire beaucoup de choses à
échanger et je pense que le président de
la république proposera des échanges
notamment sur le plan santé publique
lorsque les médicaments lorsque les
vaccins arriveront et bien les deux
grands pays que nous sommes doivent
faire en sorte de se comporter avec
générosité vis-à-vis du reste du monde
je pense que voilà des sujets qui sont
importants je pense qu'ils diront
sûrement quelque chose sur le
désarmement parce que toutes ces
politiques
on sait très bien qu actuellement dans
le monde
les politiques d'armement ne cesse de
progresser les quantités d'armes
progressent aussi
et ça coûte très cher à nano à nos pays
à nos concitoyens et on s'aperçoit que
parfois un virus né dans un marché
chinois peut provoquer beaucoup plus de
dégâts
conan provoquerait des drones ou des
chasseurs bombardiers ou des sous marins
donc je crois que c'est des sujets sur
lequel il convient bien sûr de
s'entretenir et d'essayer surtout
d'avancer et saint paul de les voir se
parler
merci et christian cambon d'avoir
répondu à nos questions je rappelle que
vous êtes sénateur les républicains du
val de marne président de la commission
sénatoriale des affaires étrangères de
la défense et des forces armées